el decreto supremo 9 con el que se
declara el estado de emergencia también
suspende derechos Como la libertad de
tránsito o el derecho a reunirse en la
práctica qué implica eso para los
ciudadanos Y qué poder tendrán las
fuerzas armadas
en realidad no suspende los derechos lo
que hace es limitar las posibilidades de
su protección judicial esto quiere decir
que las personas pueden transitar y
reunirse pero la policía sin una orden
judicial las puede detener y puede
cancelar la reunión
la la respuesta judicial se activará
solamente cuando se demuestre que no hay
una conexión entre la causa de la
declaración del estado de emergencia y
la reunión o la conducta que Está
realizando el detenido es decir si hay
una arbitrariedad por ejemplo esto el
peligro es que se tome como una carta
blanca para detener para impedir la
expresión de la protesta que es un
derecho de la de las personas que está
vigente Bueno y por un lado Dina
boluarte ya había mostrado un poco de
flexibilidad al disculparse por las 49
muertes en las protestas que ha habido
desde diciembre cuando el legislativo
derrocó al entonces presidente Pedro
Castillo Pero por otro endurece las
medidas como con este estado de
emergencia qué tanto le puede servir
esta estrategia para controlar las
protestas
mire quisiera ser dos precisiones la
primera es que el legislativo no derrocó
a Pedro Castillo Pedro Castillo da un
golpe de estado a las once de la mañana
cuando anuncia el cierre del Congreso
anuncia la
reorganización de los tribunales de
justicia y según el artículo 46 de la
Constitución ahí pierde el cargo deja de
ser presidente y nadie le debe
obediencia en la tarde el congreso hace
una parodia de procedimiento para
apropiarse de la situación y pretender
que ha destituido castillo y eso lleva
al malentendido al sur andino para
pretender para Perdón para para sentir
que un hombre del interior del campo ha
sido despojado de su cargo que así o no
ha sido despojado su cargo pero esta
imagen que ha proyectado el congreso es
la que ha percutado ha puesto en marcha
todas estas protestas Entonces yo
quisiera que quedara claro de Castillo
no ha sido derrocado por el congreso él
ha perdido el cargo cuando da un golpe
de estado y es arrestado como respondía
por la policía Y en segundo lugar la
señora boluarte pide perdón por cuarenta
y ocho muertes que son crímenes de ese
de lesa humanidad que jurídicamente no
tienen Perdón lo que Tendría que haber
hecho es decir yo no tuve ninguna
ninguna injerencia destituyo a los jefes
militares destituyo al ministro de
defensa al ministro del interior y al
Primer Ministro porque ellos estuvieron
a cargo del de la gestión de la crisis
que condujo esas muertes pero no ha
hecho nada de eso Simplemente ha perdido
perdón y ha lamentado otras situaciones
como como la pérdida de de ingresos para
el turismo la la muerte de animales Es
decir ha sido una especie de de perdón
eh que
llamémosle de alguna manera mentiroso
porque en primer lugar jurídicamente no
cabe si es que
acepta que tienen ha tenido injerencia
en estos crímenes de lesa humanidad eso
no tiene perdón jurídico no hay ni
siquiera indulto para esos crímenes y si
lo que quería era deslindar Tendría que
haber destituido a las personas que
según ella estuvieron a cargo de esto
pero no hizo nada de esto dijo al
contrario Seguiremos con la con la con
la represión sí Y discúlpame que lo
interrumpa Usted cree entonces que estas
acciones harán que boluarte de este
camino a una sustitución a ser
sustituida como ya ha pasado con otros
cinco presidentes en los últimos siete
años
Creo que creo que en la medida en que
esto Esta reacción
se mantenga esta conducta es esta
pertinacia que en en reprimir en en
trasladar la responsabilidad de las
muertes a los que protestan y no
asumirla como parte de errores
en la conducción de la política de
seguridad interior creo que es probable
que la situación social vuelva
insostenible eh que se conserve eh la
señora boluarte en la presidencia